Chuck and I are not in a negotiation of
oh we're not going for the five billion
dollars for the wall we simply are not
now that Democrats have won control of
the house did president Trump's last
best chance at getting that wall already
slipped through his fingers
earlier this year he came out swinging
against a bipartisan immigration bill
that would have funded the wall and
provided a path to citizenship for daca
recipients calling it a catastrophe in a
giant amnesty the bill failed and the
wall well still not built joining me now
is Stephen Miller senior policy adviser
to President Trump Stephen does the
president feel like this is like the
sand and the hourglass that slipped
through the to that little tiny hole
not at all first of all the bill that
you mentioned the lead in would have had
in fact been a total catastrophe and
gutted interior enforcement permanently
forever we've already built or have
underway over a hundred miles of the
wall and this stand that we're taking
right now with the entire nation
watching and frankly the whole world
watching is a stand that we think we're
gonna win the fact checkers say your
border wall claim the president said a
lot of it is already built was not true
well the fact checkers fact checkers
typically are wrong about these things
and they certainly are in this case like
the new wall like that yeah there's two
beautiful new wall there's beautiful
30-foot rock-solid bollard steel in the
ground you can go down and look at it up
high and it's 30 30 feet tall so unlike
the unlike the old well you have it in
El Centro for example you have it in the
San Diego area and in Calexico and many
other areas too but that 30 foot barrier
we're going to there I'm go I'm gonna go
just do a show from the wall maybe
they'll sit on the wall yeah did you see
that you see the old shorter barrier
yeah that predated this administration
you see people climbing over it and
throwing human beings over it you need
that 30 foot height I just want to say I
want to get to the real issue at hand
the Democrats are fighting free legal
aliens Donald Trump is fighting for
American citizens that's what this whole
things about you've covered this better
than probably anybody for years you
understand this is about sovereignty
it's about working men and women it's
about safe communities it's about wages
living conditions quality of life this
is the battle right now right before our
very eyes we are going to win because
Donald Trump is not backing down Jeff
Flake out going well you'd be surprised
to know Stephen he disagrees with you
that's watch the notion that Democrats
have prevented any fix the last real
vote we had on substantial immigration
reform was that bipartisan bill that we
did in 2013 every Democrat in the Senate
voted for that bill this notion that
this is all the Democrats fault is just
wrong is that true I mean do do
Republicans deserve some blame here I
mean we got we have a lot of Chamber of
Commerce type Republicans I just had a
guy from Cato is a nice guy but they
don't want any border they don't want
any enforcement down there they want the
cheap labor they want a glut of workers
so the wages stay down now we have a
dearth of blue-collar workers and wages
are going up well look if you zoom out
right 30,000 foot view last few decades
of American history there's no question
that both parties in America have
contributed to unwise foreign policy
unwise trade policy and unwise
immigration policy Donald Trump came
into office and has turned that all
around getting tough on China on trade
renegotiating NAFTA cracking down on the
illegal immigration dealing with
unskilled low-wage migration reorienting
our foreign policy all of these issues
Lord that that have affected working
people in our country for decades he's
turning them around but the Democrat
Party of today now the Democratic Party
of years passed on the Democratic Party
of Bill Clinton to the nineties never
cut apart we know they're off how you
gonna get how you guys gonna get
campaigned on the wall Mexico's gonna
pay for it Mexico's not gonna pay for it
unless you're gonna tell me some of
that's night that I don't know but yeah
the savings from trade alone will fund
it but I'm actually glad you're bringing
up that funding issue because just the
cost of heroin just the cost of heroin
in our country a year is 230 billion
dollars just the cost of public benefits
for illegal immigrants every year is
over a hundred we did a last night 18
billion just for the health care a year
just legal and paid for the most of the
wall right there this is what Chuck
Schumer said about the NAFTA payment
let's watch the president repeatedly
prom
that Mexico would pay for his
unnecessary and ineffective border wall
well mr. president if you say Mexico is
going to pay for the wall through NAFTA
which it certainly won't then I guess we
don't have to so first of all Chuck
Schumer was for the wall when he voted
for the secure Fence Act in 2006 and now
that it's Democrat Party has become the
party of open borders and Donald Trump
as president he's against secondly if
Chuck Schumer wants to pass legislation
saying that we can spend all of our
trade savings on border security that'd
be great in the meantime the savings
from the trade deal will offset the cost
of the wall and more importantly than
all of that the wall is going to save
American lives is going to save American
jobs and it's going to save in the long
time reform hundreds of billions of
dollars yeah you need to you need the
asylum reform and you've written about
this in the past I've certainly written
about it without that reform for people
who cross the border with a child or
someone who they say as a child it's not
child then they they're still being
released are they not they're still
being released you can't have you can't
detain and house everybody because
they're too many people so they are
effectively being released by the Trump
administration now because we don't have
reforms in place how do we do that with
a Democrat house the this is going to be
one of the defining issues of the next
two years heading into 2020 and the
Democratic Party follows the path of
open borders and the Democratic Party is
going to engage in a self immolation
Donald Trump is fighting for working
people and he's fighting to restore the
borders around this country that are the
essential ingredient for national
sovereignty and national success in a
way that nobody has who's held that
office not only in my lifetime but
frankly in the history of this country
do you feel like you can go out in
public and restaurants in washington d
in do you I have no concerns you know so
you you eat you're fine you're not it
was it was that Broadway show going on
outside your house yesterday there was
some do we have a video of it this
Raymond said it was who was it looking
like Raymond it was some cut well it was
like was it lacasa faux or was it I
don't know
who's paying these people this is just
and you weren't even there I mean but
see but you don't have walls do you
outside your house really I mean there's
no no those are the tech people that
have walls outside on eclis they'd have
a better chance of getting jobs if we
can implement some of our immigration
reforms that we've been talking about
very very very fun okay what's going on
the chief of staff search everybody
saying it's a nightmare
I mean I've heard this endlessly it's a
nightmare in the White House the spirit
is bad everyone's depressed they said
that a year ago they said that almost
two years ago number one what is the
spirit in the White House does the
spirit the spirit is wonderful not only
the wonderful spirit of this sacred
Christmas season but also the wonderful
spirit of getting to work for a leader
who is fighting for everyday ordinary
citizens just regular families in every
part of this country did your segment on
Opportunity Zones earlier
african-american Hispanic American
people who don't have powerful lobbies
powerful special interests we don't have
representation in big international
organizations our own boards of
corporate companies and large
multinational businesses just everyday
people in this country now of a champion
in the White House and getting to work
for a president who fights every day for
just normal everyday citizens is a
privilege beyond words and all the
people I work with feel the same way
they're gonna focus on the
seven-year-old who this horrific story
migrant girl who died from dehydration
after being you know brought into the
country or her parent brought her she
died you know the left will focus on
that as if that's Republicans fault for
our believing in a border that they play
the emotion game and often often times
we play the fat game facts are very
antiseptic emotional stories sell the
case immigration immigration is an
emotional issue and it ought to be an
emotional issue because it affects
people's lives and if you want to stop
the horrors on the northward track the
the rape that occurs the abuse that
occurs Dadda chol assault and the death
that occurs then for the love of God
fund the border wall stephen chris
christie chief of staff that's what
we're hearing tonight could be him any
comments I'm not gonna make any news on
the chief of staff announcement but
whoever the president chooses is going
to be somebody who shares his vision
who's who's going to work hard to
implement it and who's going to be a
great selection
even thanks for being with us what a
great holiday season